gigi and yolanda hadid just want to move
on following their recent alleged
altercation with zayn malik at the end
of the day that's all that's what it's
all about a source tells et quote
yolanda is upset that her situation with
zane came to light as is zayn gigi and
yolanda are fine and never had an issue
over the incident the source adds quote
at the end of the day zayn will be in
the family's lives forever and everyone
hopes one day they can all move on
according to court documents obtained by
et the alleged incident occurred on
september 29th at the pennsylvania home
where the model and former one direction
singer have been raising their 13 month
old daughter kai
zayn allegedly quote shoved yolanda into
a dresser causing mental anguish and
physical pain after shouting profanities
at the 57 year old former real
housewives of beverly hills star in a
statement to et the pillow talk singer
adamantly denied striking yolanda but
has since pleaded no contest to four
counts of harassment in a statement
released on twitter at the time zane
explains in part quote i agreed to not
contest claims arising from an argument
i had with a family member this was and
still should be a private matter but it
seems for now there is divisiveness and
despite my efforts to restore us to a
peaceful family environment that will
allow for me to co-parent my daughter in
a manner in which she deserves
a source previously told et that zayn
and gigi who have dated on and off since
2015 have called it quits amid the
allegations
he's obviously so gorgeous but
really the way that we could have
conversations and kind of just
were really interested in the same
things and it was really easy as for kai
e t sore says gigi asked her mom to
watch her daughter while she was working
in paris
but a second source tells et a different
story about who was watching their
daughter when the incident went down
quote zayn's mother was in town from the
uk for a special visit and she was at
gigi and zayn's apartment watching kai
and helping
and zayn he was put on a 90-day
probation for each of his four counts of
harassment
360 days total and was ordered to
complete an anger management class and
domestic violence program
additionally the singer must not contact
yolanda or the security guard that was
on the property during the incident whom
he allegedly attempted to fight
according to the docs the judge could
terminate his probation if all
conditions are met within six months of
course this all comes after a source
previously told et that yolanda and zane
had a disagreement that quote turned
hostile adding that gigi was not there
when the alleged incident transpired and
listened to both sides of the story a
rep for the 26 year old model told et at
the time quote gigi is solely focused on
the best for kai she asks for privacy
during this time
you